How is it that society has not learned from history about the dangers of
socialism,
Marxism,
ideology,
et Cetera,
after years,
how to Marxists get away with it?
Well,
let's,
let's not go with the dangers of etiology.
Let's go with the dangers of like call it radical left wing ideology.
Well,
I think the reason for this,
and this also might buy the reason,
be the reason that there's a strange thing that the iconography of,
of social communism is still acceptable socially,
whereas the iconography of Nazi-ism isn't.
Now,
I'm not saying that we should make the icons of Nazi as socially acceptable
either.
I think that the communist icon shouldn't be socially acceptable,
but they are.
And there's probably a reason for that.
You know,
now,
part of it is that the left has never taken on.
The radical left has ne never taken responsibility for being on the same side as
the Stalinists and the Maoists and the Cambodian murderers and all of that.
So that's part of it.
But then the next part is I think there's something deeper.
I think that,
you know,
inequality is a reality and it's a reality that cannot be put at the feet of
capitalism or at the feet of human political structure.
There's a good book you guys might want to read this called the great leveler by
Walter Shy Dale and it's a new book and it's the study of inequality.
And one of the things he does is do an empirical analysis of the relationship
between inequality,
the Gini Coefficient,
which is a measure of inequality and the ideological position of governments.
So here's the theory.
The hypothesis would be,
well,
because the left wingers are concerned with inequality,
if you measured inequality in left wing under left wing governments and you
measured inequality under right wing governments,
you'd expect a reduction in inequality under left wing governments.
And the results are
okay,
no difference.
And so what does that mean?
It doesn't mean that left wings are hypocrites,
although it might mean that because people can be hypocrites.
But what it means is the problem of inequality is so intractable that we don't
know of any appropriate
political sociological or economic solutions that actually work.
It's a real catastrophe.
Now,
inequality in itself might not be a bad thing unless it's too extreme.
It's extreme.
When people say start to starve and then clearly somethings,
you know it's,
it's very difficult to,
I think everyone would agree that that's a suboptimal outcome.
You know,
we don't need to get all ideological about that,
but some degree of inequality is useful because,
well,
it gives people something to strive for.
It gives them an op,
right?
It means,
I was thinking about this,
sometimes you actually want people to be rich because if a new product is
introduced into the market,
the people there have to be people around who have substantial pools of capital
to be able to afford it when it's still novel.
And then that market brings the price down for everyone else.
And so if everyone had exactly the same income,
it would be very difficult to introduce expensive products into the market with
the hope that their price would plummet.
Not actually is a big deal.
You want large pools of capital sitting around too,
so that people can invest in very,
very complex things.
And you also want large pools of capital to be the hands have to be in the hands
of private individuals so that there's competitive,
there's forces that are powerful,
that are competitive with the government and with other large organizations.
So anyways though,
back to the Marxists,
despite the fact that there are reasons for inequality and despite the fact that
you can't lay the fact of inequality at the feet of capitalism and despite the
fact that capitalism also appears to be making every one not absolutely poor at
the same time as it makes some people very rich,
there's still inequality is still painful reality and no one really likes it.
You know?
I mean you can lord it over someone,
I suppose,
and,
and extract out some sense of your moral superiority because you happen to
occupy a hierarchical position that's higher.
And sometimes there's some validity in that,
especially if you've earned it.
Although I would say like glorying in it is probably a suboptimal outcome.
It's still the case that that inequality violates a moral intuition that
everyone has.
I think,
and that's probably the moral intuitions that lie along the agreeable access.
It's like,
well,
wouldn't it be better if everyone had enough?
It's like,
well,
who argues with that?
You know,
I mean,
everyone feels that way.
And so I think,
um,
a thoughtless,
a thoughtless compassion makes Marxism,
okay.
Naively attractive.
And I'm not being cynical about that because there is some utility in naive
agreeableness,
but unfortunately the world is a very complicated place.
And merely wanting to be nice about things and wishing that everything was fair
doesn't justify imposing an equity outcome and Gerrymandering,
complex economic systems that will bite you if you mess with them because you're
ideologically possessed.
I am 46,
retired executive,
wealthy,
competent and full of Jews.
Who could I talk to if I want to invest time slash money slash energy in your
university
people,
lots of people are,
are asking me such things and it's very much appreciated.
It's a weird,
you know,
because you'd think that if people are offering you time and money that it would
be a straight forward thing to say,
yes,
please climb aboard and help.
But it's not that simple because first of all,
I don't want to involve people in something that I can't be sufficiently
committed to.
It's not fair to them.
Um,
and it isn't obvious to me how I can be committed to this yet fully committed to
it.
And so I'm sort of playing with it at the level that I can manage.
It's not like it's a game.
We have a good product in involved or a good product in,
in motion at the moment,
but I'm not,
I don't have the wherewithal to scale at the moment.
And you know,
you can say,
and people who are developing new businesses like to do this,
like let's say I could come up with a draft business plan for an online
university and then I could contact people like you,
Paul and say,
look,
I'm ready to gather investments in,
let's say I could raise $20 million or let's say I could raise $200 million.
Then I have a new problem.
The problem is,
well,
Oh my God,
I've got all this money now I have to figure out something to do with it.
And that's actually a really big responsibility.
Not,
it's not like,
you know,
it's a success catastrophe,
let's say it's a first world problem.
I get all that,
but that doesn't mean that it isn't real.
So I have to do a lot more thinking and planning
and figure out how to disperse my time most effectively before I dare to take on
any additional people who would like to help.
Now,
once my organization as it is in a place where that sort of help would be
useful,
then I'll make a public announcement and I would be more than happy for people
to jump on board.
Let's say climb on board,
start pushing,
devote resources,
all of those things.
I'd be happy for that to happen that,
but I don't want to do it prematurely because I don't want people to,
to risk their valuable resources in an endeavor that isn't yet solid.
So,
all right,
so I'm only going to do,
I think one more question.
Um,
I am a sober alcoholic slash drug addict.
How can I find my way back to belief in a higher power after 10 years in the
empty void of atheism,
I'm falling apart.
Well,
I would say your best bet is to actually start devoting some time to it.
You know,
for me,
I became convinced of the validity of a religious viewpoint.
I think as a consequence of study
read,
Joseph Campbell read Carl Young Young's hard.
Campbell's a good introduction though.
Richa Ellie out as well.
I don't know if you can find your way back to belief,
but you might be able to find your way back to meaningful engagement and that
might,
that's a better way of thinking about it.
You know,
the belief thing is a really tricky one.
People ask me,
do you believe in God?
And I think,
I really think,
how dare you ask that question.
I think that's really what I think.
Yeah.
But on a more prosaic level,
I usually think,
well,
I don't know what you mean by belief.
I don't know what you mean by belief and I don't know what you mean by God.
These are very,
these,
these are very difficult questions and none of that self evident.
Now I would say,
do I believe in the crucifixion?
Well,
certainly,
I mean people,
the crucifixion,
how can you not believe in it if,
if you think symbolically,
it's like human beings are,
we're eternally crucified,
right?
Our lives are tragic and they end in death and were,
we're all betrayed.
We're all betrayed.
We all experienced betrayal.
So how could you,
you can't not believe in the crucifixion.
Do you believe in the resurrection?
Well,
people die and are reborn all the time.
You know,
they go through,
this is what you're after here.
I'm a sober drug and alcohol and drug addict.
Well,
you know,
you,
you had to let a lot of you die when you stop being an addict and something new
be reborn.
It's like what's the ultimate significance of that and how is it tied to the
notion of bodily resurrection?
Well,
I don't know what the ultimate significance is,
but it does seem to be the pathway through life
to believe.
I would say you start believing not by attempting to
convince yourself that the statement there is a god is true,
like a fact is true,
but to act out the proposition that you should shoulder your cross and stumble
uphill towards the city of God.
That's belief,
man,
and you can do that
right away.
Now you might ask,
well,
do I have any guarantee that that has transcendent and universal significance?
It's like,
well,
it's not a bad model for emulation.
It has universal significance in that regard.
We each have to shoulder the tragedy of our existence and stumble upwards.
Despite that it has universal significance.
Does it have significance outside of life and like get the internal eternal
realm?
Okay.
I wouldn't surprise me if it did.
I suppose it depends on what you mean by the eternal realm.
The
seems to have significance in the eternal realm of consciousness.
It seems to have significance in the eternal realm of unconscious fantasy,
implicit fantasy and mythology.
How is it connected with the factual world?
Okay.
That's a hard question because the factual world in some sense divorced itself
from that transcendental world during the development of the scientific
methodology.
So never the Twain shall meet.
It's a methodological issue.
In part,
I think you probably have to draw on the same forces that enabled you to sober
up and abandoned your drug addiction.
No,
something was guiding you forward.
Go forward again,
go forward again,
as if there is a higher power.
That's your manifestation of faith.
Go forward again,
as if being is benevolent and God is good.
That's the hallmark of courage
and that's a good place to stop.
Thank you all for showing up today and uh,
and for all the support and,
and that's enough for March,
March 4th,
2018 bye bye.